hi I'm Eric Voss and Iron Man Tony Stark
sadly left us in Avengers endgame and
along with his wit his charm his
well-seasoned salt-and-pepper hair
Starks brilliant encyclopedic mind also
departed our world taking all of its
secrets to the grave now the biggest
tragedy of this of course is that we
here at new rockstars pledged to
investigate every character in the MCU
because Captain Marvel established that
shape-shifting Skrulls are on the loose
characters whom in the comics have
infiltrated every aspect of life
including the ranks of the Avengers
themselves endgame may have ended the
game but the search goes on and as
ridiculous possibly offensive and
probably not even remotely true as this
all is
we must nonetheless dig up Tony Stark's
rotting and extra-crispy corpse ignoring
the tearful screams of pepper and Morgan
as we plunge our hands into its chest
because we must know the truth was Tony
Stark this quirky beyond humanely
intelligent and durable mystery man of
way too many talents a scroll we'll find
out in this episode of look our paranoia
in this scroll search doesn't come from
nowhere folks in the Marvel Secret
Invasion Comics number one one of the
scrolls has been brainwashed into
thinking he's Tony Stark so yeah there's
definitely precedence of Skrulls posing
as Stark in the comics when our search
began it was for the missing scroll from
Captain Marvel remember there were four
Talos to Science Guy the one disguised
as Coulson and the one Carol Danvers
chased on the train who got away never
be seen again now I think we can rule
out Tony Stark for a missing scroll
number four Tony was born in 1970 and
was already a rising public figure in
1995 when Captain Marvel took place sure
missing scroll number four could have
like killed a 25 year old Tony Stark and
then took his place but why would he do
that like if you're trying to blend into
human society there are billions of
other less famous humans to hide as like
saying in the real world if you're an
alien trying to lay low you don't
disguise yourself as Elon Musk guy
already looks like an alien
instead the case I am going to make is
that Tony Stark was born before you get
triggered smash that dislike button and
comment no and then click back to
pornhub where you probably were two
minutes ago remember that we're just
covering our bases with this girl search
and every MCU character is a person of
interest and Tony's
while recently deceased is a fictional
character whom my outlandish theories
are free to retcon look I'm not putting
all my chips on this one saying it's
true it probably isn't but the least
likely scenario is still worth
considering and the most fun so consider
the new insights that we learned about
Tony's father Howard Stark from the past
to Marvel films Avengers endgame and
Captain Marvel an endgame Tony Stark
went back to the day of his birth in
1972 the shield base at Camp Lee high
running into his father Howard while
stealing the tesseract Tony asks Howard
why he has flowers Howard says my wife
is expecting then Tony gets this
perplexed look he inquires how far along
is she
Howard shrugs holds his hand over his
belly to imply her womb size and he
jokes she's at the point where she
doesn't like the sound of Mike chewing
now Tony's reaction is a bit odd right
like Tony chose this date and time
specifically because he knew Howard
Stark would be there at work like he
must have known that at the time of his
birth his father was just leaving
workshop so why would this information
surprise Tony is it possible that these
circumstances of Tony's birth were just
a little strange is it possible that by
not knowing how far along his wife was
Howard Stark was hinting at the
confusion over another species gestation
period is it possible that his wife
hating the sound of his chewing is
because the sound of teeth grinding food
sounds really annoying when it's coming
from the mouth of a scroll that's right
Howard Stark also lets go uh-oh we just
lost a few more enjoy pornhub why would
Howard Stark be a scroll you might ask
well I Captain Marvel there is a very
missable detail regarding the tesseract
previously in the MCU history the
tesseract was always in the possession
of Howard Stark following the events of
the first Captain America but Captain
Marvel revealed that sometime before the
late 80s an exiled Kree scientist named
Marvel got a hold of it experimenting on
the tesseract to build a Lightspeed
engine to help the scroll find a new
homeworld
away from the Kree why would Howard
Stark share his precious tesseract with
some random alien unless Howard was also
a scroll refugee embedded on earth high
in the ranks of its government forces
seeking an escape for himself in his
people in Captain Marvel Marvel's notes
on the marooned Skrull ship included a
sketch of the tesseract
very similar to the ones in Howard
Starks notes from Iron Man 2 so there
must have
in a connection between these two and
maybe that is why Howard said things
were distant between him and his wife
Marvel died in 1989 and Bucky murdered
Howard Stark in 1991 so they never got
to see any dream of using the tesseract
to help the squirrel escape which
Captain Marvel did at the end of her
movie but if this is true this could
explain how Howard Stark and Tony Stark
are such technological wizards inventing
flying cars in the 40s working on super
soldiers technology inventing arc
reactors no one else can dozens of
generations of suits of armor and
eventually cracking the code of freaking
time travel this could explain why Tony
Stark grew up as a secretive sociopath
with serious daddy issues because he was
forced to keep his scroll identity a
secret his entire life feeling that he
doesn't belong on this planet
surrounding himself with advanced alien
like tech joking about UFO sightings
with Peter Parker and when Stark snuck a
scanner on shields computer in the first
Avengers to get access to all of their
archives he did not seem to alert them
that Hydra had secretly taken over their
organization and he even lent Nick Fury
his repulsor technology for his
helicarrier's in Winter Soldier that
Hydra would manipulate
think about this is a guy who spent a
career building advanced weaponry why
maybe to help this planet defend itself
from any potential alien invaders like
the militaristic Kree Empire that made
him in his father refugees that could
explain why Tony Stark was way more
terrified than any of the other Avengers
of another alien invasion like they all
fought in a battle of New York but
really Tony was the only one who was so
paranoid about building a suit of armor
around the world and in the first
Ironman when Tony built his first flying
Iron Man's suit what is the first thing
he does he flies to the stars he flies
to the stars again and Avengers again an
infinity war maybe because space is his
real home and yeah we should just
acknowledge that beyond a brain that's
just too smart to be human right the
Tony Stark's body is weird I'm not just
talking about that moment when pepper
stuck her hand in his chest and it was
filled with like gooey pus with zero
blood though that was also kind of
freaky he said it was discharged from
the reactor but it's weird there was no
blood Tony
famously gets very little sleep he can
withstand crazy physical damage
even I won't boy getting impaled by
thanos in the gut need to spray some
crazy advanced sealant on the wound and
an in-game when this freaky body finally
expires we never saw what they did with
the body combination did they sink him
in that lake instead of a burial plot
end game ended with a floating wreath
and peppers proof Tony Stark as a heart
arc reactor perhaps that reactor was
hiding the truth that the mechanical
heart that Tony Stark engineered for
himself
was the closest to a true human heart
that this scroll in disguise would ever
get yeah yeah I hear your comments and
stretch it stretch spree sure stretch
yeah I know it's a stretch guys I know
there's plenty of other anecdotal
evidence you can find there other movies
Oh like if you got knocked out when you
revert to a scroll yeah yeah yeah sure
sure
well you know what the stretching is the
point folks if you want to get to the
truth you got a stretch for it who
should we investigate next in our scrubs
comment down below to let me know and
follow me on instagram and twitter at
Ieva subscribe to new rockstars more
batch Marvel theories thanks for joining
me in Oh some of you are back from
pornhub great oh I don't like being the
bread of that sandwich a very astute
observation soon